-You know, our next guest
from her work
on "Russian Doll"
and "The Morning Show."
Her new film,"Past Lives,"
is available everywhere.
Now let’s take a look...
-[ Speaking in Korean ]
[ Speaking in Korean ]
♪♪
-[ Speaking in Korean ]
-[ Chuckles ]
-Please welcome to the show
Greta Lee, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi, Greta.
-Hi.
-I am so happy
you’re here.
I love this movie so much.
-Oh. Thank you. You saw it.
-I did see it.
Everybody has to see it.
-Yes.
-There’s a moment --
Have you seen it --
much with, uh,
audiences full of people?
-No, I haven’t.
-You haven't.
-I really want
to watch it on the plane,
but I think that would be weird.
-Oh, yeah?
-Like if I did that.
-That's true. Right.
-If you were watching it.
-Yeah, if I was.
And crying at my own movie.
-Yeah.
-I don’t know, I feel like that
would be a little weird.
-It is a really good crier.
And I should note,
this is not a movie
that is tragic in any way,
but it is --
-I don’t know.
[ Sighs ]
-it’s optimistically tragic.
-Soulful.
Optimistically, yeah. Tragic.
-Yeah.
-That’s a good way
of putting it.
-Yeah.
-There’s a moment in the film,
I think, you know,
and I don’t want
to give anything away.
I would want to see it
in a theater if I were you,
because I feel like
half the audience
would just go like,
[Shakily] "huh?"
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Like, that’s what I did.
-I think I know what moment
you mean towards the end,
maybe?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Or just at the beginning.
Right?
Right off the bat.
-No, no, I had one at the end
that really got me.
-Yeah.
And one of our producers,
uh, who said, you know,
Sarah said, "When I watched it,
just FYI,
I watched it in my office
and I fully cried at my desk,"
and I was like,
"Hahaha, Sarah."
And I gave her a real hard time.
And then...
And then I watched it,
and I fully cried at my desk.
-Yeah.
It can be a dehydrating
experience.
-It’s very dehydrating.
Now, this, uh, this movie,
uh, well, again, it’s, uh --
-Made you cry.
-Made me cry.
-Yeah.
-But you, uh, you play someone
who leaves a career
when you’re 12 years old
and moves to New York City,
and it’s about, uh, you know,
someone you knew
when you were 12
and sort of that reconnection
with somebody like this.
This is a wonderful film
that was written
and directed by Celine Song.
-Yep.
-And how much of it
did you know?
Did she fill you in?
Was this autobiographical
for her?
-Yeah,
it actually happened to her.
She -- The seed of the movie
was when she was actually
sitting between her,
her husband, her Jewish husband,
who lives in New York with her,
and her actual
childhood sweetheart
who had come to visit her
from Korea.
Um, and she said
that that moment felt
so, uh, hard to explain,
that it would take a whole movie
just to explain
what that felt like.
-That’s fantastic.
-Mm-hmm. Yeah.
-Now, uh, your parents, uh,
they immigrated from Korea.
-Yeah.
-And, uh, were they excited
that you were doing
a film like this?
-No.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-They were sort of like. Why?
-Yeah.
-But you --
And one of the things
you had to take,
you, uh, speak Korean,
but you had to --
You took it very seriously,
and you wanted to speak
Korean like somebody who left
when they were 12.
-Right. And that
was the whole thing.
And that was part
of their doubt.
They were like, you, you’re --
you’re going to do
a full movie in Korean.
-They thought you weren’t
Korean enough to do it.
-Yeah, they were
deeply concerned.
They were like,
that’s our daughter.
You know, we can’t let her
humiliate herself.
-Did they, like,
call the director.
And they’re like, you’ve made
a terrible mistake.
-Almost. Almost.
-Yeah.
-No, I mean that, the language
part of it, it is --
Okay. Anyone who speaks
two languages or is bicultural,
that is such
a vulnerable thing to show.
And language is so fluid.
And, you know,
as you become Americanized,
you -- you lose some
of your native language.
And what we did was we worked
with this incredible woman,
Sharon Choi,
who a lot of people know
as Bong Joon ho’s translator.
-Oh, wow.
-She’s amazing.
And because she can
translate jokes on the spot
and that, to me,
is a true master.
-Yes. Of course.
-Yeah.
So we worked together
to figure out,
like, if what a New Yorker
who’s turned into sort of
like an annoying theater girl,
like what her Korean
would sound like.
So maybe --
-That's really great.
-Yes. It’s very specific.
You know, only the most annoying
Korean theater girls
know what that is,
and we need to honor that.
-Yeah.
-Representation --
It’s a very serious thing.
-Absolutely.
And I think they would let you
know if you came up short.
-They would definitely. Yes.
-That’s where the annoying
comes in.
-Yeah. That’s right.
-So when your parents,
for example,
first saw the trailer,
did they think,
"Oh, my God, she did it."
-They texted me
when they saw the trailer.
They said,
"Why is this in Korean?"
[ Laughter ]
-So they just hadn't listened.
-Parents don’t listen.
-No they don’t.
-They don’t listen.
And now that I’m a parent,
I agree we don’t listen.
-Uh, so your boys are almost
the same age as my boys.
Are they --
Do they know what you do?
Like mine are slowly coming to.
It’s dawning on them.
-Yeah, they don’t
give a [bleep].
-Okay.
-Do yours?
-But I would imagine --
-They don’t give a sh--
No, they like that
people say hi to me.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, okay.
-I think they like the idea.
-The bar is really low
for them.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well I think they like,
live in New York
and they’re like,
nobody says hi to anybody.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Um, but you’re I would
imagine more now, right?
Because of this film.
Like, people must approach you
and I’m assuming
you’re very nice.
-Yes.
There is some crying, though,
which might add to the confusion
and sort of like why my children
would be even
more dismissive of everything.
-People come up to you and are
so affected by the film.
When they say hello,
they start to cry.
-Yeah, like imagine you’re at --
you’re at Trader Joe’s
and you’re trying to buy cereal.
-Yeah.
-And someone comes up
to you and they say,
"Oh my God, like,
I just saw your movie."
And you’re thinking, great,
that’s so wonderful.
And then they immediately
start to bawl.
-Yeah, I mean, I imagine
that’s hard for you.
I imagine that’s so traumatic
for a seven and a four year old.
-It is, it is, it is.
And I hate to say that they’ve
sort of gotten used to it.
-Yeah.
-So.
-Oh that’s --
But do they --
I mean, obviously
you haven’t made a lot of work
that is like very friendly
to seven and four year olds.
Have they like --
Did they watch
you even show them the trailer
for something like they.
-Well, they saw --
My oldest, Apollo, is --
is a very serious dude.
And he, uh, saw the trailer
and he was completely silent
the whole time
and expressionless.
And when it finished,
he just said,
"Looks like a good movie,"
and walked away.
[ Laughter ]
That’s --
That’s like, pretty good.
In our household.
-That’s pretty good. Yeah.
-If one of my kids
said that to me, I would --
I would start crying like I’d
just seen "Past Lives" again.
-Yeah, basically.
That would be
my "Past Lives" moment.
If they were like,
"That’s pretty good."
-They also do this thing.
I don’t know if you have this.
I mean it --
Winning awards
is a very new kind of thing
for me as a concept.
But how are your children
with the actual physical award?
Because my kids are so critical,
they want to know
they’re like, what is that?
They’re like, is that Sapphire?
-Yeah.
-Like, no, it’s plastic.
They're like, "Oh, okay."
-Not to not to name drop.
We’ve got one Emmy in the house.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Um, I won it.
Not my wife and, uh.
-Important.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Important to get out there.
-But, uh,
they did have a moment
where they were like,
they’ve just noticed it,
and they’re like "Real gold"?
-Right.
And I’m like, "No."
And they’re like, [Groans].
Yeah, like, [ Sighs ].
-They're like,
"Maybe one day, Daddy."
-Yeah. I’m like,
what are you --
And if it was real gold,
what would you do?
-Melt it down.
-Yeah.
They're immediately like,
"Your awards are short term.
This is money, Dad."
-Exactly.
So practical.
-It’s so practical.
-Yeah.
-It’s just such a beautiful
film.
And congratulations...
Thank you.
-...on, uh, your Critics Choice
nomination, and...
-Yeah.
-Well deserved.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, it is.
But can I just say
that I right now,
in this moment, I’m --
I’m just thinking about
something totally different.
And I’m carrying around
a lot of shame.
I just learned
that I am responsible
for committing a heinous crime
because there’s something
called a Kimjang,
which is this traditional event
where back thousands,
maybe centuries
of years ago,
Koreans would gather together
as a community
with all of their hard-earned
resources and make kimchi.
Right. So we do this event.
And this year,
it happened to fall
right after the Academy gala.
And Charles Melton came
with his mother, Sandra Oh.
-Very good.
-All the fancy Koreans.
And I just learned
that I single-handedly
ruined the kimchi.
-No, how?
-I didn’t wash it enough.
-Oh my God.
-I know. But it's like --
-I'm gonna act like I know
that’s bad.
-Yes, should be like,
"Oh, my God."
-You've gotta wash it enough.
-Yes.
No, but, Seth,
this is really bad.
It’s basically like I’ve killed
the whole village.
-Oh, my God.
-Yes.
And it’s like the village has
decided, like, send her away.
Let her be an actor.
It’s safer for everyone.
-You’ve been cast out?
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
-I’ve been fired.
Well, I hope
they let you back in.
Maybe if they -- if they haven’t
seen this movie and they see it,
I think they’re going to
let you back in.
-You think so?
-I do.
-Okay.
-Thank you for being here.
Will you, please,
come back soon?
-I would love to come back.
-Oh, my God.
Greta Lee, everyone.
"Past Lives"
is available everywhere now.
Go and see it.
We’ll be right back
with chef Rick Martinez.